president Bollinger in golden dean freed
distinguished members of the faculty
honored graduates family friends guests
welcome to the 2010 commencement
ceremony for the valence School of
Public Health today we celebrate a
commencement a beginning where we're
also forced to acknowledge and mourn a
loss as well Cynthia Felix a master's
candidate here at the mailman School of
Public Health a colleague a friend and a
loved one lost her life tragically early
saturday morning in an automobile
accident she was known to many of us and
was a part of the cohort that celebrates
commencement today we cannot go forth
with this otherwise joyous celebration
without acknowledging her passing
Cynthia represented that which is so
powerfully present here today she was
part of and contributed to the diversity
that is the mailman community in the
face of that diversity the traditional
prayer that is often offered as an
invocation in many graduation ceremonies
is not part of the tradition here at
maleman we rejoice instead in our
diversity by acknowledging that we are
many faiths we are many cultures many
traditions and many beliefs and thus the
spirit that we invoke is our commitment
to the highest traditions of Public
Health the commitment to work to ensure
that health is recognized as a
fundamental human right and wherever
possible we commit to work to create the
conditions that will make that right a
living breathing reality that committed
that commitment that dedication is what
brought Cynthia Felix and many of you to
the mailman family she will never
realize the work that she came here to
do she will not take up the task but she
dedicated her life to
complete so in this day when we
celebrate new beginnings when we
celebrated commencement let us keep her
in our hearts and make her struggle our
own and to the graduating class may you
find success fulfillment and most of all
joy in the bright future that I know
lays ahead broad you welcome Dean breed
I present the graduating class 2010
mailman School of Public Health thank
you all
good afternoon it is my great pleasure
to welcome you to the 2010 commencement
ceremony of the Columbia University
mailman School of Public Health please
join me in welcoming our friends on the
dais including distinguished colleagues
invited guests and especially mrs.
Phyllis Melman president of the Joseph L
Melman foundation and please join me as
well in welcoming our distinguished
guests in the audience including members
of the Melman family our Board of
Overseers mrs. Claire rosenfield and all
mailman school alumni who joined the
procession today we are thrilled that
you are here with us for such an
important celebration and now to our
graduates from where I stand it's a big
WOW it is quite a view from over here
all of us are on the dais are taking
taking in what appears to be a veritable
sea of joy the joy expressed in your
eyes and in your smiles and on the faces
of your families your friends and your
professors so today as we honor you and
recognize your achievements we also
honor your family friends and professors
who have done everything possible and
occasionally the seemingly impossible to
help you realize your goals class of
2010 please stand up turn around and
show them just how much their support
men
and to our graduates you have
demonstrated that you thrive in an
environment the cherishes free-thinking
scientific inquiry critical analysis
respect and inclusion responsible and
ethical decision-making and intellectual
hard work you have demonstrated that you
know that when it comes to public health
there is no them only us and you have
demonstrated that you are ready to
engage the public health challenges of
our day and the global health challenges
of our century take the next steps in
your journey with the same energy
determination and optimism that brought
you to New York City to Columbia
University to the mailman School of
Public Health and here to commencement
day we are also very proud of you and we
will continue to expect fabulous things
from you congratulations to the mailman
school of public health class of 2010
it is my deep honor now to introduce
president Li si Bollinger of columbia
university president Bollinger became
the 19th president of Columbia
University in 2002 he is one of the
country's foremost legal scholars on
free speech and First Amendment issues
president Bollinger is recognized as a
visionary in leading Columbia University
to create itself as a truly global
University while strengthening at the
same time our ties to our city and our
bonds with our neighboring communities
he is one of the most important
champions of this mailman School of
Public Health he recognizes the
leadership needed from public health
science scholarship and translation into
impact to improve our world president
Bollinger
so first of all congratulations to all
the graduates and welcome to their
parents and families and friends we
gather today to celebrate the remarkable
achievements of this class of 2010 let
me return the thanks and recognition to
Dean Linda freed who has been an
outstanding Dean for the past two years
to make the mailman school really one of
the stunning schools of Public Health in
in the world so thank you very much
Linda and let me also pay regard to dr.
Lee Goldman executive vice president for
health and biomedical sciences and Dean
of the faculties of health sciences and
medicine the Goldman joined us also just
a few years ago from the west coast and
has brought tremendous energy and focus
and order to Washington Heights thank
you very much League
I'm also very pleased to welcome mrs.
Phyllis maleman very close friend of all
of us here and the mailman family her
son Josh and his wife Monica and her
daughter Jodie and her two daughters
Joanna and Livia in 1998 mrs. maleman
and her two children made the
extraordinary commitment to colombia to
name the school in honor of her late
husband joseph lawrence mailman Phyllis
and the family thank you very very much
so I'm going to have my chance at the
podium when we gather tomorrow for
commencement so let me just cuase a very
quickly a few things you definitely have
your work cut out for you for all the
progress we've made in public health in
recent years there are many others that
continue to grow and need your attention
after decades of political battles we
finally have achieved a version of
health care reform that says what seems
so obvious and yet has taken so long
reform that says that health care and
quality health care is everyone's right
in this country not just for a
privileged few I know
I know that some of our guests today and
one guest in particular understands as
few do just how remarkable it is that
the political star is finally aligned to
take that step in the United States but
what we make of that opportunity here at
home and in the years ahead and how we
address the enormous public health
challenges we confront across the globe
will depend in large part upon you we
already know of your commitment public
service is not only a professional goal
of your coming here a goal shared by
thousands of students across the
university but it has been an essential
part of an education at Columbia and no
where else more so than here at the
mailman School of Public Health you have
a Dean and you have an institution that
are dedicated in the most fundamental
ways to applying the interdisciplinary
knowledge of a great research university
to the most important real-world
problems facing our society here and
abroad there is no field I can think of
that has more opportunity to affect the
lives of more people than public health
and I think of you is really privileged
to be part of that and I certainly honor
you for the choice to pursue the
education and the roles that you have I
can also think of no better person to
address you today as you embark on the
next steps of your journey than former
President Bill Clinton President Clinton
is not only our uptown neighbor but a
friend who has become a regular part of
the public dialogue on our campus each
year the last time he was with us just a
few months ago it was for world's World
AIDS Day supported by the William
Jefferson Clinton Foundation it was down
at lerner
hall and quite appropriately led by our
own remarkable doctor wathah al Sadr who
is director of the international center
for AIDS care and treatment programs
here at maleman a few years earlier I
had the privilege of sharing the stage
with President Clinton and vaclav havel
who was had a residency on our campus in
his impressive and energetic host White
House life President Clinton has made
global health a central feature of his
work and I was of the work of his
foundation from leading the fight
against hiv/aids to making enormous
strides in environmental protection
efforts to advancing education and
employment opportunities for children
and adults around the world as well as
his extraordinary leadership in global
disaster recovery efforts President
Clinton has demonstrated just how many
acts there are in a life of public
service some people in our lives hold a
very special place in our imagination
and I think President Clinton is one of
those few individuals and for him to
have led all of us in thinking about our
responsibilities to the world in the
ways that he have has is a great great
act of leadership may we all be blessed
with the same endurance dedication and
determination to change the world as we
would wish it to be so for tomorrow I
hope to see you there I hope it doesn't
rain and if it does we will amend the
agenda and do it much more quickly but
it's great to be with you today thank
you very much
so it is now my great pleasure to
introduce dr. Lee Goldman our executive
vice president for health and biomedical
sciences and Dean of the faculties of
medicine and health sciences dr. Goldman
is an extraordinary leader in the world
of academic medicine and an
internationally recognized expert in
health outcomes research he has a master
public health degree as well as an md
degree and holds faculty appointments in
the College of Physicians and Surgeons
and in our mailman school public health
where he is a professor of Epidemiology
we are so fortunate and I say that on a
daily basis to have someone of dr.
Goldman stature informing overseeing and
supporting our efforts and goals it is
my honor to welcome a true friend to the
school and to me personally dr. Lee
Goldman
dr. Freid thank you dr. Freid president
Bollinger soon to be here President
Clinton distinguished faculty graduates
family and friends of the class of 2010
or as I've learned recently 2k10 to be
more modern my remarks will be brief
because as you notice from your program
I am sandwiched in between two
presidents I can't tell though I'm
supposed to be the turkey or the ham
I'll try to avoid being either let me
just say is dr. Frieden decay that I
also have a degree in public health and
that public health degree has greatly
influenced the way I look at the world
and self reinforced my moral compass as
a teacher a researcher and a provider of
direct medical care the link between the
medical care component and the public
health component of our system needs
work dr. Frieden hyman working very hard
together for the past two years to
develop models that we hope will help
inform you and your successors as we
bring these two fields more closely
together so that the benefit of each can
be complemented by the other for those
of you who may follow basketball I used
to be taller you know the NBA playoffs
are in a high gear and for years one of
the superstars of the NBA was Karl
Malone why do I bring that up here at
the graduation well some of you may
remember that Karl Malone had a nickname
he was called the mailman he was called
a mailman because he always delivered
much like the mailman family has been so
generous here it didn't matter how
difficult the circumstances were it
didn't matter how limited his teammates
might seem he got more out of the team
and they did better well graduates here
colombia's Mailman School of Public
Health are also renowned worldwide
because they always deliver they deliver
domestically they deliver globally the
delivering research and teaching and in
public service now today as you graduate
this very big space is almost it's
standing room only lots of people are
here to welcome you and to participate
and all things you've accomplished we
know in public health we don't always
work in the spotlight sometimes we work
in places we were lucky if there's any
light at all and it's very special about
public health is it regardless of the
circumstances regardless of who's
watching regardless of whether anyone is
there to applaud people in public health
do the right thing they make the world
better we know you'll continue with this
wonderful tradition of using your skills
your energy your dedication and your
education to the little to deliver the
best to humanity here domestically and
worldwide congratulations to you all
and now it is my extraordinary privilege
to introduce our keynote speaker and
this year's recipient of the deans
Distinguished Service Award in public
health since leaving the presidency and
starting the Clinton Foundation
President Clinton has redefined the
field of global health offering
visionary leadership towards innovative
and comprehensive approaches to some of
the most complex and life-threatening
problems our world faces today problems
that require both leadership and an
understanding that some changes and some
benefits require all of us acting
together on on each other's behalf
President Clinton's groundbreaking work
and climate change considers the major
sources of greenhouse gas emissions as
well as the people policies and
practices that impact them his rapid
intervention after the earthquake in
Haiti and now ongoing long-term work in
Haiti has saved countless lives and
alleviated unbearable pain and suffering
his aspirations are fueling a vision for
a Haiti rebuilt better equipped to
harness the resilience and the
indomitable spirit of her people and the
strength of our culture and natural
resources so that she may build back
better and compete successfully in the
regional and global economies indeed our
students and faculty working on the
ground in Haiti helped all told us that
it is President Clinton who is setting
the pace for an accelerated recovery
driven by an effective deployment of
resources and his dream of what can be
for the future the reach of the Clinton
Foundation and its impact on global
health is in a word extraordinary
whether it is marshaling support for the
treatment of AIDS in developing
countries providing cataract surgeries
for underserved populations in Peru
enabling farmers to plant millions of
fruit seedlings in Rwanda or
implementing a rural health program in
Papua New Guinea President Clinton and
his foundation are making the world a
better stronger more compassionate and a
healthier place in which to live it is a
lasting legacy we honor and embrace
today President Clinton as Dean of
Columbia University's mailman School of
Public Health it is my deep honor to
introduce you as our commencement
speaker and to present to you the twenty
ten Dean's Distinguished Service Award
in recognition of your visionary
leadership and enduring commitment to
global public health ladies and
gentlemen let us welcome President Bill
Clinton
thank you very much thank you very much
Dean free president Bollinger mr.
Goldman this is maleman ladies and
gentlemen I want to thank the faculty
and staff the students who are
graduating for giving me a chance to
share this special day I think the
family and friends who are here who
helped to students I'd like to begin by
expressing my personal profound
appreciation to the mailman school for
four reasons first of all you gave me a
chance to come see my daughter get a
degree
secondly Dean frites predecessor dr.
Alan rosenfield helped me to established
our hiv/aids program around the world
and without the invaluable assistance of
the mailman school I'm not sure we could
have gotten up and going thirdly thank
you very much I became friends with dr.
Rosen field and I watched him handled
ALS disease which has affected other
friends of mine and family members of
some of my closest friends and I never
saw a man handle his impending end of
life with more dignity or make more out
of the life that he had left and
finally I am very grateful to you for
the work that people from the mailman
school did in Haiti immediately after
the earthquake and continue to do their
for mental health now protection and the
long term rebuilding of the health care
system I thank all the graduates for
your commitment to doing public health
work how public health issues are
resolved are left unresolved will shape
much of the 21st century and I want to
make five simple points today first the
obvious one represented by you the
interdependent world of the 21st century
is a fascinating place it is more
diverse than ever before as the crowd of
tests there's more access to more
information more quickly than ever
before there are more scientific and
technological advances coming at us than
ever before most interesting one
recently has been the finding in the
treasure trove of genome studies that
between one and four percent of our
genetic makeup was contributed by
Neanderthals our pre-human ancestors I
keep wondering if that will excuse every
mistake I made going back to my fourth
birthday I can only say that I was
delighted that women as well as men have
Neanderthal genes otherwise the
late-night comics would have fodder for
decades to come the second point I want
to make is that for all of its joys this
world has a lot of challenges as we all
know
the benefits of the modern world fall
unevenly among countries and within
countries and people handle being on the
short end of the benefits in different
ways I've said in other places and I
might as well say here I think a lot of
the wackiest things that are happening
in American politics today really
reflect a cry of despair from people who
just want all this change to stop so
they can find some solid ground to stand
on Virginia for example has terrible
budget problems so when the governor of
Virginia issued that Proclamation to
bring back Confederacy month and didn't
mention slavery until Prada to do so I
don't think he suddenly became more
racist I think he was responding to all
those people who feel that they have no
solid ground to stand on and so they're
saying stop the world I want to get off
I want to go back to some time when I
was in control of something the problem
with that approach is you can't stop the
world and you can't get off and so we
have to look honestly at what the
challenges are essentially they fall I
believe into three categories the world
is too unequal it is too unstable and it
is completely unsustainable because of
the way we produce and consume energy
and all of those have serious public
health implications if you look at
inequality half the world's people live
on less than two dollars a day before
the earthquake more than seventy percent
of Haitians who are living on less than
two dollars a day but there are massive
public health implications a billion
people have no access to clean water 2.6
billion people have no access to
sanitation a billion people go to bed
hungry every night
before the earthquake Katie had no
national health system there was an
interesting article in the press this
week as you might imagine I get all the
clips worldwide on Haiti and read them
every day about how some people are
actually getting better health care now
for the makeshift hospitals that people
like you have gone down to set up than
they were before the quake but there are
still massive public health problems
there with the rainy season coming on
even if no hurricane hits a tent city
and blows it down and damages people
there will be puddles of water
everywhere in a place that has no
adequate sanitation and every boy or
girl with a cut on his or her foot he
steps in a puddle of water is at risk of
contracting a waterborne disease one in
four of all deaths on earth every year
come from AIDS tuberculosis malaria and
infections related diseases related to
dirty water eighty percent of the people
in the last category are children five
and under and I worry about it every day
when the earthquake hit Haiti 87 metric
tons of food had been pre-positioned in
El Salvador because the Caribbean is
both a hurricane center and an
earthquake action area and the world
prepared for that and that food was a
godsend in the beginning I don't know
what we'd have done without it but I
found very quickly that there was no
such reserve of sanitation equipment and
no reserve production capacity so we
emailed every producer of compost
toilets and other sanitation traditional
sanitation people in the world and paid
for everything we could pay for and got
everything we could get there as quick
as we could and they're still wasn't
enough and so now
there may be a second wave of tragedies
in Haiti because of the inequalities of
the modern world in healthcare the world
you live in is highly unstable you see
it in the financial crisis which began
here spread to Europe spread to Asia
hurt our friends in Latin America you
see it now with the problems of Greece
imperiling the European Union and very
idea of the common currency and now the
Federal Reserve has opened a line of
credit for European countries because
the American stock market is being held
down by fears that the contagion could
spread here from tiny Greece part of big
Europe part of the big world but you
also saw it when the SARS epidemic
started on mainland China's Fred to Hong
Kong turns up into rubble and all the
perils associated with swine flu which
thank God didn't fully materialize
partly because everybody worked so hard
on it but cases show up in Mexico and
they close the Fort Worth school
district for several weeks we had a case
diagnosed in New York and total
strangers would come up to Hilary me on
the weekends we were walking in
Chappaqua New York asking if they could
still take their kids to a Broadway play
so the instability of the modern world
is manifest in healthcare too and in
many other ways that you all know and
the unsustainability of climate change
has enormous public health implications
if the worst calculations proved right
and we don't reduce our greenhouse gases
by enough quickly enough it's estimated
that by 2050 we'll have to move at least
a hundred million people away from
coastal cities will lose 50 feet of
Manhattan Island okay here we're in the
middle of the island enough we'll only
use 50 feet around
there'll be vast changes in food
production patterns with unpredictable
consequences more drying up of
freshwater sources when we've already
got a billion people without access to
fresh water and already you see it in
the changes going on in Australia
ironically the next hardest countries to
be hit according to the climate models
will be countries least able to handle
it including Afghanistan and Haiti and
sub-saharan Africa and there are evident
consequences now last year for the first
time in history more fish was consumed
which was grown by fish farmers than
which were found naturally in the oceans
rivers and lakes of the world why
because the oceans are partly because
they are overfished and partly because
increasingly the chemical content of the
oceans changing as they bravely absorb
more carbon dioxide and are therefore
less able to support large fish
populations and we have no idea often
what these fish that are farmed are
being fed all of which will have
enormous implications in the future so
if you're in the public health business
you have to ask yourself what are the
public health consequences of inequality
and instability and unsustainability and
what is the response is it changing a
government policy changing personal
behavior or changing the nature of
healthcare delivery the next point I
want to make is that
the problems of the modern world are
fundamentally different in poor and rich
countries in poor countries the problem
essentially boils down to this it's a
problem of capacity of systems there are
many different life stories in this
class and doubtless many of you had to
overcome great obstacles to get where
you are I'm sure several members of this
class for the first person in your
family ever to get a degree nonetheless
you did have access to systems that
brought you to these chairs today and
many of them you take for granted you'd
be shocked at the air conditioning went
off for the lights failed or the
microphone failed and you couldn't hear
a word I'm saying you just take it for
granted much of the work I do now is in
places in the world where people can
take none of this for granted where
people every bit as smart as you who are
willing to work as hard as you have have
no predictable beneficial consequence
from the acts they take in those places
the work of Public Health is system
building so that there are predictable
consequences to constructive efforts and
in Haiti what we're trying to do is not
in health care we're not trying to build
back better in education we're not
trying to build back better we're really
trying to build wealth for the very
first time they have never had a health
care system even though they have two of
the finest NGO public health efforts in
the world Partners in Health headed by
dr. Paul Farmer and guess Keogh headed
by dr. bill pap which is the oldest AIDS
clinic in the world outside the United
States but they've never really had a
national health system partners in
health and our foundation work to build
one for the first time in Rwanda
and they now have first-class hospitals
in every region of the country satellite
clinics and community health workers
trying to go into every village in the
country we're trying to do the same
thing in Malawi and the suits are now
that's what we have to do in Haiti and
in many other places throughout the
world President Obama and the Secretary
of State has advocated that America
changed the focus of its aid program to
try to help other countries do this it's
really important my foundation has more
than 100 people working in Ethiopia now
because nobody in Ethiopia is going to
die of AIDS because of the
unavailability of medicine or because
the money is not there to pay for it but
they are going to die of AIDS because
the country has 80 million people and 58
million of them live in sixty thousand
villages of a thousand or less and when
we began there were only seven hundred
clinics for those sixty thousand
villages so they figured the Ethiopians
if they build 3,500 everybody will at
least be within a day's walk of the
clinic and if they have AIDS or
tuberculosis and malaria at least they
can be kept alive if there the women are
pregnant at least they can get some
basic maternal care this is important
they have to build the systems now in
the wealthy countries the problems are
just the reverse we have systems that's
how we grew rich our problems are that
the system's become impervious to change
they become too rigid people gain a
greater interest in preserving their
position within the system and advancing
the purpose for which the system was
created in the first place and that's
why it was so hard for so long to get
health care reform in America I mean
we're spending 17.2 percent of gdp on
health care to ensure eighty-four
percent of the people none of our
wealthy competitors spends more than ten
Oh Switzerland at 11 and a half but
there an overpopulation in remote alpine
villages of the extremely expensive
delivery system but all the other major
countries are between nine and ten and a
half percent of GDP that means we spend
a trillion dollars more on health care
than we would spend if we had any other
country system so some of the people
getting the trillion dollars wanted in
theory to ensure a hundred percent of
the people but in practice there was
always something wrong with whatever
plan was proposed which is why I'm very
glad that we adopted the health care
reform bill even though it isn't perfect
and the workers just begun but the truth
is we had to keep changing and public
health will have a lot to say about that
one of the good things about to build
that almost nobody knows is that senator
Sanders got about ten billion dollars in
there to expand public health clinics
what are they going to do are they going
to treat the people who still won't have
insurance they're going to treat the
immigrants who are here who won't be in
the system can they do more to provide
preventive and primary care at
affordable prices to people who want to
buy insurance should they be able to buy
into some plan that the public health
clinics will offer somebody should be
thinking about this it's a public health
issue that can change the rigidity of
the system look at the obesity problem
in America number one public health
problem in the country and interestingly
enough it is a problem of prosperity
that affects overwhelmingly the
unprocessed is obesity is on the other
side of knife edge the knife edge of
hunger and it becomes a problem in every
country that develops an urbanized
middle class it's a big problem in India
now there are more people dying of heart
attacks strokes and
cancers in India than aids the UK and
Ireland have national campaigns against
childhood obesity huge public health
problem because it is a reflection of
what we eat whether we exercise the
working patterns of parents how much
time they have to buy and prepare food
what kind of food they can afford and in
the case of the United States and in
some places other places it's also a
function of how we produce and market
food these are enormous public health
issues the estimate is that obesity
alone already adds a hundred and fifty
billion dollars a year to America's
health care bill I think that's quite
conservative I can't prove it but I
think it's a lot more so we do a lot of
work on this my foundation has made an
agreement with the soft-drink people
that will has reduced by eighty eight
percent the caloric content of drinks
sold in public schools in America it's
just the beginning but we have to
re-examine this issue and it may be that
the way we produce and market our food
will have to change it's a public health
issue that can't be dealt with solely
with a treatment response and there are
lots of other examples like this but I
think the way we pay for medicine is a
public health issue if we pay for
procedure instead of for overall care
and wellness will get more procedures
whether we get more wellness or not and
we'll run the bill up all of these
things require a public health response
now besides the problems of poor
countries in the problems of rich
countries there's the whole issue of how
they relate to each other and what they
do the Global Fund on AIDS TB and
malaria the PEPFAR program started under
President Bush these were great public
health responses but how we do this
really matters and we're reaching a
crisis now I'm worried about the eighth
effort for the first time in a decade
because the economic crisis means the
Global Fund is underfunded so far this
year the United States was asked by
countries all over the world to spend
more money on building out health
systems so you deal with maternal and
child health issues other basic health
issues but with the budget caps that
they got it leaves less money to
increase the PEPFAR program for AIDS and
malaria and the Gates Foundation which
has helped my foundation a lot in
subsidizing artemisinin-based malaria
drugs in 11 countries in Africa and I
have talked a lot about how we can make
the money go further change the delivery
system these are serious public health
problems Uganda has already had to stop
taking new aids patients think about
that they're now four or five million
people that I keep getting different
numbers on antiretrovirals in the
developing world our foundation
negotiated low-cost contracts that serve
about half of them including two-thirds
of all the kids but what happens when
you're running a country and you're
treating 300,000 people and the three
hundred and first thousand person that
shows up is turned away in an effect
given an end of life sentence how are we
going to deal with this what would you
do it's a public health issue
how about the way we give food aid
there's still a lot of hunger in the
world and in the United States and we
have record use of food stamps record
use of the food banks food banks are out
of food in America but think about the
way we give food aid in the United
States we still say that except in an
absolute emergency the food that we give
has to be grown in the United States and
shipped on American flag shifts we were
giving food to Haiti for example grown
not in the Dominican Republic with grown
in the United States Canada had the same
rule and a few years ago they started
giving half their aid from food into
place closest to the famine or the
hunger which meant the money went
further the food got there quicker and
you supported local agriculture and a
more sustainable food environment we
ought to do that in all the differences
i have with president bush that's one
thing that I agreed with him on and we
were virtually alone in the Republican
and the Democratic Party nobody in
Congress would help us because they were
afraid of the farm lobby we can afford
this and our farmers can afford this we
have a good foreign support program we
don't need to do this we could save
fifty thousand more lives every year
just by changing the way we give food
aid that's the public health issue and
it's something you ought to be heard on
we need the thinking of people who
understand public health as we make
these excruciating ly difficult
decisions about whether to build out a
health care network or buy more medicine
and keep in mind when you build out the
healthcare network you're going to have
even greater demand for the medicine why
I have the prevention programs in so
much of the developing world failed when
it comes to AIDS and can anything be
done to make them more effective there's
plenty of money being spent trying to
develop
an AIDS vaccine or a cure but we're
still not there yet and until we get
there we have to think about this
finally there are lots of other issues
that affect multinational development
clean water how much of our age should
be given and clean water and shouldn't
it be considered a public health issue
shouldn't we think about the energy
policies we support in other countries
in terms of air quality whether people
are burning kerosene in small Hut's in
developing countries are belching coal
and old-fashioned generators when in
much of the developing world it is sunny
and hot and windy while we're trying to
put up more solar panels and solar
thermal facilities and windmills in
America shouldn't there be an aggressive
effort to give that to other people
Hillary announced the other day that the
United States was going to try to do
something to help the Caribbean become
more self-sufficient in energy because
our neighbors there have the highest
electric rates in the world because they
have to import all their energy
virtually every island in the Caribbean
could be completely self-sufficient with
solar and wind shouldn't we be doing
that for public health reasons as well
as for economic reasons these are the
kinds of connections that you will have
to make in your lifetime if you want the
world to work for more people the final
point I want to make is this
whether you go into the private sector
or work for a public agency here or
another country or an international
agency or you work for an NGO you will
do public health because there is public
health and all of these things we have
discussed and everything you do should
be put through the filter that I
mentioned is it integrating in the world
are disintegrating the world is it
promoting the positive forces of
interdependence health education
well-being are the negative ones in a
quantity instability unsustainability if
it's doing the former it's good if it's
doing the ladder it's not the world your
children and grandchildren will live in
will be determined by your success in
reducing the positive the negative and
building up the positive forces of our
interdependence and public health is at
the core of every single traumatic issue
one final point on the genome when we
finished sequencing it with the
expenditure a lot of your tax money in
2000 as a political person the thing I
found most interesting was the initial
conclusion that from a genomic
standpoint we're all 99.9 percent the
same and then craig Venter did another
study and said oh hold it we're not
we're only 99.5 percent the same now all
of you know with three billion elements
in the genome four tenths of one percent
is a significant number but from a
social political and philosophical point
of view it's not very much it means if
you look around this crowd every single
difference you can see from the color of
your skin to the color of your eyes to
the shape of your body to your gender
every non age-related difference you
can see is rooted in somewhere between
one tenth of one percent and five tenths
of one percent of your whole biological
being and yet everybody spends 90
percent of their time worrying about the
one tenth of one percent now my position
is in the world you're living in since
you can't stop it you can't get off and
you can't put up walls again we need to
spend a lot more time we're at about the
ninety-nine point nine percent we need
to understand it the only way we can
appreciate celebrate and enhance the
impact of our diversity what is special
about us is to always always believed
that our common humanity matters more if
we do we'll have good public health
policies and if we do you live in the
most interesting prosperous peaceful
exciting time in human history every one
of you carry some portion of
responsibility to make that happen thank
you very much
Thank You President Clinton and
hopefully you could hear me as I as you
walk out the building that the work that
you're doing in my country of Haiti
words cannot describe thank you so very
much to present the teaching excellence
award in the early career teaching award
the recipients of whom are chosen by our
graduates I will call on Tian Wu and say
jovis washing two of our graduating
students who have participated in
various student group leadership
capacities at the school we will begin
with the presentation of the teaching
excellence award ladies and gentlemen it
gives me great pleasure to announce this
year's teaching excellence of war
recipient professor james cole grow from
the department of social medical
sciences
students and colleagues have described
professor call Grove as compassionate
and kind with the genuine concern for
students and a professor who teaches not
only public health as it is practice but
also a public health as we think it
should be practiced moreover and his
persuasion and coercion and public
health course he clearly demonstrated
his passion for teaching by actively
engaging his students to reconsider the
assumptions and ethics of today's public
health practices and once a month he
would bring delicious baked goods from
his very own kitchen his class was so
vibrant and dynamic that students were
always eager to be there every Wednesday
morning this clearly shows the kind of
remarkable teacher that he is when we
all agree that most graduate students
are not wanting people but to truly
understand his talents as a professor
you should also know that he has
published various articles and top
journals were critically acclaimed book
on the history of immunization and
co-authored the first book on the
history of public health surveillance to
upson over 100 years indeed professor
call Grove embodies both teaching and
scholarly excellence without a doubt
he's an invaluable part of our mailman
school experience please join me again
in congratulating professor call group
author and educator William Arthur Ward
once noted the mediocre teacher tells
the good teacher explains superior
teacher demonstrates the great teacher
inspires the recipient of the naw girl
early career teaching award dr. Martina
Pavlik ova from the department of
biostatistics exemplifies for the oats
great teacher
in her introduction to bios to take this
course professor pava cova has
demonstrated an unwavering commitment to
making complex and intimidating material
accessible to students of all
backgrounds her lectures are renowned
not only being clear and concise but
also engaging humorous and dare we say
fun for those who require additional
help professor Pablo cova spends
countless hours in her office meeting
with them even on Friday evenings her
dedication is unequivocal always looking
to go above and beyond the role of
teaching professor pelvic ova also has
many other areas of expertise such as
weekend planner she often encourages
students to take advantage of the wide
array of weekend events in New York as
long as they take their biostatistics
notes with them some may even describe
her as a matchmaker as one student noted
she not only helped me learn stats but
she helped me find my eternal love for
it her ability to challenge students to
apply statistics to other classes and
disciplines distinguishes her as a great
teacher one student exclaimed that this
first semester course was a first way
that I understood the values that
mailman school was teaching me echoing
that sentiment another student remarked
she's motivated me to achieve my dreams
and attain all that I desire please join
me in congratulating dr. Martine Apollo
cova on her contribution accomplishments
it is my great honor to recognize two
faculty members who receive the
university presidential teaching awards
doctors cushman and sparrow could you
please stand this award is the highest
teaching award that can be given to a
faculty member at the University this
year is a great privilege for the Melman
school to have two out of the five
University recipients to come from our
faculty congratulations dr. Fishman
install the student commencement speech
given on behalf of the graduating class
will be presented by aashka shah good
afternoon and welcome Dean Linda freed
commencement speaker president William
Jefferson Clinton who gave a rousing
speech earlier esteemed guests mrs.
maleman esteemed faculty families and
the graduating students of the mailman
class of 2010
as a medical and public health student
I'm often asked the question how can a
group of diverse individuals of unique
backgrounds and experiences work
together to serve the needs of our
communities the answer is one that we
have collectively discovered over the
course of our journey at maleman
henceforth it is this answer that we
must carry in our minds and hearts as we
begin to define ourselves our work and
the health of our society we are a
system an elegant and complex system of
values beliefs physical
interconnectedness natural processes and
unfathomable depths of discovery we are
integrated starting from our biology and
we carve a niche for ourselves in the
greater society we suffer we realize we
apply we live selflessly and we
sacrifice we are the heart and soul we
are public health this
this interdependence between man and
society is one that is often ignored in
day-to-day business however it is this
intricate relationship that we as
mailman graduates have come to
appreciate throughout the course of our
studies we have explored relationships
between health & policy challenged
intellectual dogmas and designed
revolutionary practices we learned from
each other's experiences and applied
these public health pearls in our unique
practice settings whether halfway across
the world or in the backyard of
Washington Heights we learned how to
become advocates for our communities our
patients and our vision for a better
healthier world now much like the
evolution of man social evolution takes
time it is not unlikely that we will run
into obstacles along the way as we
define our careers and the help of our
society great movements of progress
characterized today's domestic and
international landscapes of public
health the United States is poised to
usher in an era of healthcare reform
that will place greater responsibility
on protecting and preserving the health
of our communities at the same time
everybody from NGOs to the private
citizen has donated their time skills
and resources
to healing the wounds and rebuilding the
infrastructure of Haiti as students we
have learned to recognize the challenges
presented by our intertwined
environments and we have embraced the
responsibility as set forth by Dean
freed to deliver hope and compassion
over the course of our journey at
Millman we have learned the value of
building relationships and how
instrumental these are in shaping how we
think about the world and each other
each of us here today has identified
mentors who have inspired us in the
classroom and in the field they have
taught us the value of interdisciplinary
collaboration and of the great import
the communities provide to our work as
we approach the challenges that await us
upon our graduation we must keep in mind
the relationships we have forged along
our journey for it is these
relationships that will give us the
clarity of thought the appreciation of
innovation and the authority of our
approaches in protecting and preserving
the health of our communities in the end
how is it then that a group of diverse
individuals of unique backgrounds and
experiences can work together to serve
the needs of our communities quite
simply through a shared foundation
enriched and inspired by our colleagues
parents faculty and esteemed guests
hosted by this university with the
appreciation and understanding of the
interdependence shared between man and
society we become the very existence the
heart and soul of Public Health moving
forward we become living proof for a
better tomorrow congratulations and best
wishes to the mailman class of 2010
earlier today we held a student awards
ceremony and reception in recognition of
excellence in scholarship and service I
would like to call your attention to the
list of outstanding students who receive
these awards which is located in your
program congratulations to all the
awardees now for the moment of the most
expensive ticket in town Dean lap and I
will present the candidates for
graduation to assist with the
presentation we have asked lily and
Morales and Charles Liriano from the
Office of Student Affairs to join us it
is our privilege today to present to
Dean freed candidates for the degrees of
Master of Public Health and master of
science and public health we will first
present the Master of Public Health
graduates Dean free I am pleased to
present to you candidates for the degree
of Master of Public Health Eleanor Adams
Catherine a de- andrea i doona newport
agrawal Mauricio aguayo falasha day a
dry Eva a karate Sonja alam syeda Asia
alley
Sydney 11 Derek Anderson Phoebe are they
aqua Teresa argan desi Vanessa our NATO
Alicia Atwood Ganga deep babra Cyrus
betcha Lauren daily Samara box sure
Anton Banerjee sushi bansal Catherine
barong
and a berry gesture Colin Baines
Alexandra Beltre Ariana Bennett Lena
bolero Sonali belote car Edna bonham
Natasha bolero and ballzack Catalina
Bravo Katherine Britain Kevin brummett
Kirby Bumpus Benjamin Bynum Angela
Campbell Amy cannon
Jesse car Caitlin shot on it Michelle
ciao Polly Chen Judy Chang miku Chang
Jason shirt off Diana child's Jennifer
kayenta Michelle Cohen Christina call
Vivian Cortez Kristen car smelling
Amanda crane
take in color Emily Dawson
jessica de Mulder Marianne do it Emily
Donaldson
Danielle dreamer Carolyn Eberle Joshua
Ehrlich when Elwood Claire SB tina pham
amanda far nerded Ferrante Marianne
feedback simonis ish
John Flores
or not Gaffney Gina gambone Darien
Garcia
Tiffany Garcia Jesse gasps Sega Genesis
Richard Gill Galina Galina Madeline
gandhigram Giselle go PES Rebecca Gordon
Cherie grace Monica janeski Jackson
Guerrero jyoti Gupta
akira jamira junghwan ha David Hanson
Norma Alicia a low Catherine hensel
Susan hora key Christina hope Elizabeth
one yak Julie helped
melody show Amy Huber Craig hutchinson
Nicole Aimee zara ismail ruby jane
Shelby Jergens Darren Jackson
and Johnston Judith came Yuki can I do
Justin Kang any cow Sarah captain
Levinson Colleen coughs umalas Timothy
Kang
I Lacan myriad korrasami tonia couch on
Donny Lia kiefer tay sushant Kim taejin
Kim Lori King Geoffrey Kenyan asmara
nitin Sunita krishna reddy sonaze
Kulkarni
Jason quang Alicia likami Gabrielle
Lamoriello Simone Lawson Simon Lee David
Lee Margaret Leggett Logan Leinster
Valerie lumen Chancellor's janushka last
I Zoe liverman Maria licious Laura
Latonia Lisa less aha Meredith loss
ohne k Lundy d'cruz Emily magid Joanne
my Gregory Mac Jennifer mall Robin
Forrestal mangini Peter may hang
Sonja Marcus Jessica mark then I'm Marty
Maria martin & McMullen deja McPherson
Yolanda mere your Bali Ravi mishra Jovan
Mitchell
Sarah Mirage are daniela Morales Lauren
your head Maureen Murphy Kathleen Meyer
stephenie meyer's shefali math Gretchen
Nelson Amy new alt leave edita neogi
victoria no juku
Sean nowicki Irene insiya Maria O'Brien
Francesca okole an 30 luya Tyler are
strander Allison pack sang-woo pack
author panel
maria papadimitriou Christina parinello
Lily pues on Julie Pearson Jennifer pair
Christina persaud Francois Picard Jesse
pink off Christopher pot OSHA
Seth friends Angela Poulin and quant a
veena raghavan surya ram Michael
rhinaman Caitlin Reiner Elizabeth
Reynolds
Brennan roads Siobhan Riley brittney
robinson Joelle Robinson Rita Rodriguez
Christine Roman Curia rose Meredith
Rossi Laura right now Caitlin Ruth rious
kiva jasmine sat at mont Mandana Mandy
sahadi knee y le saldana Jonathan salud
Laura Salvatore Oh mommy some pong
Jessica Sanford sumin sehran Sarah shoe
jennifer huger amis Scott Kimberly see
back Brenda Siana
I saw saw swati sharma shaky Sherpa
rifka chilson Laura Sherman
manisha see djibouti Josie Silverman
Kathleen Bernadette Simmons Erica
Simmons Amy schlechte amber sligar yacht
sec slov Kowski Emily smeargle Dana
smiles
Emily Smith Aaron Sneider nyomi Sorkin
eleni soo Lee opolis Lindsay Spiros
Bridget Staley Christine to pula Caitlin
Sweeney Megan swarm tomorrow Taggart
Melissa tan aundrea Monique Thomas nyala
Thompson lashandra Thornton shootie
tiwari hoods I tongue canola anupama
torgul surely tour ho Danielle Tracy
Victoria trinis and two
Sonny Paul sejal vashi Julia fish
Nowitzki Caroline Wallace Lauren was
Angie Wayne Ellen web
Scott Weber Aaron wheeler amber wit sir
Allison whitehead Jennifer Wu Tian Wu
Rebecca yow Jean Ezra young I hon you're
at
aki hoshino and last on the list but
first to lead TJ Dean freed I present to
you the candidates for Master of Science
royale che lei Harmon I'll Chilton oh uh
none bow aunt the vizio sobbing you'll
slamming Kristen kasasa
Todd case Kathleen 30 Benjamin fresh
Anjali ganda Shuang hub alexander ii
rabanne sneha jacobs sangha jeena bhai
tahay jobin putra benjamin level wall
Leonard Lieberman
ashutosh mishra Sean o Mahony earnest
Pugh Amanda pong Richard smealey Laura
Snell Elizabeth Vernon Giulio Vera
shunpei wrong and last on the list and
also first to lead jin way the School of
Public Health collaborates with the
Graduate School of Arts and Sciences to
offer the PhD degree in biostatistics
Environmental Health Sciences
epidemiology and social medical sciences
these graduates participate in a
convocation ceremony and at the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences but we are
pleased that several of them have been
able to join us here today there are
important members of our school and we
honor their achievements the chairs of
our departments will offer doctoral
degrees will not present their
candidates for the degrees of Doctor of
Public Health and Doctor of Philosophy
doctor and dr. Andrew Davidson executive
vice dean will hood the candidates we
begin with biostatistics with dr. Bruce
Levin
I will now present to Dean free the
candidates for the degree of Doctor of
Public Health in the department of
biostatistics Richard J cow
I will now present to Dean free the
candidates for the degree of Doctor of
Philosophy in the department of
biostatistics rose Itza borislav ova
dimova Shing Burnley
Dean freed it is my honor to present to
you the candidates for Doctor of
Philosophy in the Department of
Environmental Health Sciences young fa
che
Saturn xueling one
Igor sure react
team freed it's my pleasure and honor to
introduce the candidates for Doctor of
Philosophy and epidemiology Sarah
Bronstein Heidi greenberger this might
take a while
and Matson danna March and Vivian
Santiago colon
be afraid it is my distinct honor and
pleasure to introduce candidates for
Doctor of public health from the
Department of Health Policy and
management Catherine row Dean freed it's
my privilege to present to you the
candidates for the degree of doctor of
Public Health and the Department of
socio medical sciences Karen rocio
Flores Alicia kokoschka lukacs go pardon
me
faith Miller settee
Jennifer Pierre as your Thompson
Dean free it is now my honor to present
to you the candidates for the degree of
Doctor of Philosophy in socia medical
sciences Ashley Fox Benjamin Mason Meyer
and the person with the most patients in
the room Alicia Peters
well what a fabulous fabulous class of
graduates we are so proud of you
from for everyone here who has looked on
with great pride at your accomplishments
and there are so many of us we
congratulate you now before we conclude
our ceremony we have one more ceremony
to complete and that is to affirm our
commitment as public health
professionals by reading together the
public health oath found in the last
pages of your program the oath is but
one of many innovations of the mailman
School of Public Health and it's nearly
90 years of history the oath was
developed by a group of mailman school
faculty members and students across the
school it was written to express the
ideals and the professional commitments
that all of us in public health hold
dear today is the ideal opportunity for
us to join and read together what has
become an annual part of our public
health commencement ceremony to our
graduates faculty and alumni I ask that
you please stand and join me in reading
the public health oath health is a human
right the public health community exists
to safeguard that right I believe it is
a defining element of a civil society
public health represents the collective
actions necessary to protect the health
of all people through prevention science
and practice we can accomplish this goal
as a public health professional guided
by these
it's apples I declare the following I
will work to ensure that people have the
chance to live full and productive lives
free from avoidable disease and
disability and supported in their
pursuit of physical mental and social
well-being I will hold myself to the
highest ethics standards values and
responsibilities as I move forward the
science and practice of Public Health I
will respect the rights values beliefs
and cultures of those individuals and
communities with whom I work I will rely
on evidence to support my decisions and
actions and translate that evidence into
policies and programs that improve
health for all I will add to the body of
research and knowledge and share my
discoveries freely I will continuously
seek new information and be open to
ideas that can better protect and
promote the health of populations I will
advance health literacy for all and seek
equity and justice for vulnerable
populations with this oath I commit to
the ideals and mission of Public Health
with the reading of this public health
oath we conclude our wonderful
commencement ceremonies and shear our
graduates as they commence the next
stages of their careers congratulations
this marks the conclusion of this year's
commencement ceremony I hope you all
will join us in celebrating the fabulous
achievements of these graduates and the
completion of a very exciting academic
year at a reception to be held on this
floor of the armory just beyond the edge
of our ceremony area we ask that all
guests please remain seated until our
faculty and graduates have recessed
graduates please remain where you are
until you are directed by the ushers to
recess after the faculty recession thank
you again and congratulations
you